des pistes de ski désertes des remontées
mécaniques à l'arrêt année noire pour
les stations de ski crise du coville 19
oblige pour les professionnels du
secteur cette année s'annonce difficile
qu'il est loin l'âge d'or des stations
de sports d'hiver entamée au début des
années cinquante amateurs de sports
d'hiver est née cette nouvelle station
c'est courchevel dans les alpes nous
sommes en 1952
l'une des premières stations de ski
touristique en france est situé à plus
de 1800 mètres d'altitude de la mi
décembre à la mi mai on peut descendre
sauter tout à son aise car un excellent
tremplin deux se complètent le tableau
à l'origine le ski c'est surtout une
affaire de montagnards et de gens
fortunés mais à partir des années 60
le tout risque de mal se développe le
ski se démocratise
comme à val d'isère en savoie en 1962
l'industrie des remontées mécaniques
téléphérique ou téléski entrepris à
l'immense effort d'équipement
modernisation des gares facilité d'accès
au guichet ou au portillon écoulement
des skieurs sans bousculades sont
recherchés la station de ski des saisies
toujours en savoir sort de terre en 1964
à plus de 1600 mètres d'altitude pour le
plus grand bonheur des skieurs
s'il vous plaît que pensez-vous de la
piste est très bonne mais j'ai ici c'est
le principal et vous monsieur on va ça
colle un peu le gouvernement flers
l'intérêt économique des sports d'hiver
il lance le plan neige dès 1964 objectif
créer et aménager des stations de haute
montagne à gourette dans les pyrénées
les remontées mécaniques sortent de
terre
les logements aussi il faut construire
toujours plus même à plus de 2400 mètres
d'altitude
parmi les réalisations en cours la
principale et l'ensemble qu'on appelle
les résidences du valentin qui comporte
à la fois un parking couvert qui
atteindra 200 places et 400 studio est
un ensemble commercial et administratif
début des années soixante dix la
tendance se confirme mais cette
construction massive a ses limites bloc
de béton qui s'amoncellent paysage caché
par les infrastructures
c'est ce que dénonce cet architecte en
1973 pascal alpe d'huez nous sommes sur
un terrain particulièrement fragile
parce que le site et sans aucune
végétation et toutes les constructions
qu'on implante l'alpe d'huez ont un
impact dans le site considérable
pourtant les stations de ski vont
continuer leur essor
toujours plus de touristes vont affluer
en 2019 52,8 millions de personnes ont
visité les domaines skiables en france
[Musique]